va bene
ciao chiarissimo meno male che l'avete
spiegato perché prima non avevo capito
visto che tutto in arabo di 36 un figli
al nostro zitto piuttosto mettili questa
maschera questi non parlerà più per il
resto del vietri borsetta dell'inter
profumare in bagno 6 queste scarpe fanno
talmente schifo di tv vi appoggiate al
muro non guardarlo lo stesso fanno
quelli davano se guardi con un binocolo
dentro un euro a essere i problemi
mentali però attenzione fa il trucco di
magia
quindi non dare monete ai mendicanti che
sentano di farti trucchi di magia
sull'aereo ragazzi notiamo subito che i
giochi dell'aereo sono fatti apposta per
gli gnut hubert questo meraviglioso big
money e adesso da vedere se c'è il gioco
click bates vuol essere milionario dove
gli uccelli tradizionalmente volano in
inverno nord est sud ibiza
bravo tudor bravo ok ragazzi siamo
arrivati in giappone sono stanco morto
di giuro la vescica mi sta esplodendo
anche perché ci state 200 ore di viaggio
appena atterrati abbiamo appena
prelevato mi chiedevo trovare un
successo assolutamente ma chiedo al
primo giapponese di turno semi come si
chiede il sesso e in giapponese
vabbè proviamo sappiamo che non si
prenda a male che lo registi amici qua
ma youtube youtube star when i'm just
arpa driving here and i'm the wish c
kayes exploding a need to find bagno che
mai attuale de toilette
pag grazie gentilissimi ragazzi e sasha
ci siamo avvantaggiati subito sul primo
distributore di bibite
indovinate quanto costa la fanta allora
anche quest'anno ci hanno messo distanza
insieme vice vedi come contento salvo di
stare come prevedere quando sei contengo
intensissimo soprattutto quando dormi
fino alle 11 di mattina
ti voglio bene anche io ho fatto la mia
valigia veramente [ __ ] grazie a tutti
grazie mille molto eterosessuale fammi
vedere
no non abbiamo letto unito ma dai ma non
lo sanno che ci sono le coppie moderne o
che veloce pigiamino guarda ma secondo
te io mi vesto così dopo l'ictus ma
neanche se devo morire mi vesto così
adesso hai capito non la sta dicendo
italia perché italia guy italia verranno
già l'hanno capito l'hanno capito e sono
capito che siamo una coppia moderna per
ragazzi siamo a tokyo è praticamente
siamo per arrivati dall aeroporto e
abbiamo preso questa stanza d'albergo al
volo perché domani ripartiamo andiamo a
kyoto
quindi questa è una stanza d'albergo
così volante per passare una notte in
compagnia però il pigiama e veramente
figo lessolo testo ma si compì già ma no
ti prego aspetta dobbiamo fare questa
roba
le indossiamo un attimo vediamo come
stiamo ci vediamo tra poco dai capelli
perché sono i personaggi di un'anima e
una paura di gianni i miei capelli
massima poi fa un caldo bestia strappa
così è un bellissimo ha legato
tagliando ma va va giù ciao ragazzi
ribelli mi sono vestito con una roba un
po più decente di quella roba questo
stato ieri sera consumi al power perché
mi andava di g non è che mi vesto sempre
da schifo ma non così tanto insieme a
noi ci sono anche i ragazzi che ci
stanno seguendo per il docufilm che mi
stanno riprendendo in questo momento
e io che sono un burbero riprendo loro
c'è un panorama
un'ora che guardo fuori dalla finestra
ma è così un bambino nel reparto
giocattoli ora guarda che cos'è aspetta
come si chiama curling che le valigie
tensione che sta arrivando da sola si è
fatto tutto testa discesa della minkia
stiamo per arrivare finalmente alla casa
di kyoto dopo 100 anni e mezzo di
viaggio e la cosa mi chiami sta
devastando perché non ho dormito o fa
meno caldo dove mi inchiesta a casa però
non ho ancora capito però a fare da
nella scena il 12 sera e ci sta visto
che siamo il tuo stipendio
ma chi è che io questa cosa ve la devo
far vedere perché non posso non farvela
vedere non posso ok questo è il cesso
questa è la maniglia anti la maniglia
aprì la porta e il sesso sia preda so
come cazzo è possibile cessi hanno
un'anima in questo paese perché nel
nostro no ma di una bozza ma che cosa
strana enorme no raga no non ho mai vino
no a zio ma tu sei lì ma tu sei
rincoglionito 6 ma tu sei rincoglionito
fallo fallo per le viuzze fallo per
l'eni comincia adesso di velenosi io
scappo te lo giuro su dio non ho mai
visto te lo giuro non ho mai visto
fin'ora gara non ho mai vista una roba
così è gigantesco e una cosa incredibile
no frate non mi ispiro a marcelo porta
ammazzo ti ammazzo trappeto ammazzo di
rete
sarà che può veramente la cosa più
schifosa via nova bere praga andiamo via
per favore perché siamo venuti giappone
allora io sono sempre stato contrario
grazie di urlare mentre facevi do io
sono sempre stato contrario nel
registrare quello che mangio perché sono
magro al cazzo e quindi maggio con una
scrofa ma non voglio fare invidia
nessuno questo quadro farvelo vedere
perché mi hanno detto che mi ha detto
papà è il cuore a cuore mi ha detto che
cuore quindi lo deve imporre e l'eur
neppure riordinando di dire quello che
rimane dopo che ti fringe zona nuova
pall
ok proviamo allora lo prova vi faccio
sapere l'ho con quei no no no no no vi
prego i dati ma riso norma più buono è
il taglio nella ripresa sembra il tipo
goffo e grasso in queste ore
beh si dica che è mangiata ragazzi siamo
entrati alle 8 siamo usciti alle 10 due
ore di mangiata incredibile abbiamo
mangiato come dei porci veramente
schifosi poi vabbè stefano mangiare
dieci persone 15 euro a testa un cazzo
perché poi in giappone il cibo non costa
una sega
mangio un sacco non so perché adesso
andiamo a casa anche perché domani
mattina devo montare questo video che
state vedendo quindi alla faccia di
quella da ragazzi ho finalmente ragazzi
sto montando il video che state vedendo
siamo arrivati che mattina del giorno
dopo
sono le 629 del mattino in italia sono
le 23 29 che non metti a fuoco
videocamera schifosa
ora ho dormito all'incirca cinque ore
che pochissimo cioè io volevo contate
che nella vita normale se dormo sette
ore e mezza invece che otto ore sono uno
zombie invece per colpa della lega
ancora non riesco a dormire otto ore
viene oggi c'è la prima giornata del
giappone perché ieri ed abbiamo passato
a viaggiare sul treno e vi farò sapere
nei prossimi blog come va a mettere un
sacco di foto su instagram quindi sulle
tener story e quindi nel caso seguitemi
lì se volete roba più immediata io spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
questo era il primo claudio del giappone
cosa non mi piace anche i vari social
che come lui visto descrizione che si
scateni ci vediamo al prossimo video
arriva lo stesso
[Musica]